Guys a video to see Mark Carlo
to see on all the times you could notice Carlo looking
I have a vibe
I feel it castle a key hoarder
Mark Miller
the guidance the under IRCC has become ruthless
irresponsible
and it's lacking compassion
without even giving them the procedural fairness
a problematic app
opening population is a cargo board
the theatre because we want you to be our voice
at least a government that I want to need idea rule
oh the null compassion
the null diluta java
the applications
no say 3 k null assess kata java
nakasur of the number katana
the khoshish karum akdo perik a refusal
pay the Bill
AK glarical errands of Ayers CC
Ayers CC the Hojonda Ayers CC the Hojonda Ayers CC
the Hojonda Ayers CC
the Hojonda Ayers CC the Hojonda
the dujiba say the client make a minor
a minor clerical error
Kita and you know by heart
give that key can the mother seeker
and you're not even giving them an opportunity
and refusing the application why
so menu please
as you'll see
the both of the concern at the time
immigrants really difficult career
and it's not the right thing
and liberals needs to take an opportunity here
to fix the things because
Marc Miller has a very ruthless
approach towards the immigrants
which should not be accepted at any platform
so I got you to see Saturday
Representative Hageo please
the
Vibes are not good. It's against us.